If you can't beat the heat this May, get inside
and chill with some brand new Netflix programming.
The streaming giant is kicking off the month
with more original films and shows than ever
before, from screamworthy sci-fi thrillers
to gut-busting comedies.
There's going to be something new for everyone
this month, so follow along as we look at
everything coming to Netflix in May 2018,
starting with the Netflix originals.
Sometimes
This international drama sees seven patients
anxiously waiting in a medical clinic for
the results of their HIV tests.
Impatient, they bribe the attendant to get
the results earlier, then struggle to come
to terms with the news that one of them is
positive.
Sometimes arrives on May 1st.
The Rain: Season 1
Sci-fi thrillers seem to be a popular catch
for Netflix, because the streaming service
is loading up on new releases in the genre.
Netflix first announced their upcoming Danish
series The Rain back in June 2017, and the
recent teasers showcase a desolate post-apocalyptic
world where being infected with a deadly virus
is as easy as getting caught in a summer shower.
All eight episodes of The Rain make landfall
on May 4th.
Anon
Starring Clive Owen and Amanda Seyfried, Netflix's
upcoming sci-fi film Anon takes place in a
future where technology has rendered anonymity,
and as a result, crime, almost nonexistent.
But when the police land on the trail of a
woman who can apparently hack into people's
neural implants and alter their perceptions
of the world, life suddenly gets a lot more
dangerous.
"Placing a moving image… in real time."
How do you stop a criminal who can change
what's right in front of your eyes?
Find out when Anon arrives on May 4th.
End Game
This new documentary from filmmakers Jeffrey
Friedman and Rob Epstein explores life at
the end of the line.
What do people feel as their final days approach?
Through a series of interviews with hospice
patients and people on life support, End Game
looks for answers to life's toughest questions.
Look for it on May 4th.
Dear White People: Season 2
This satirical comedy generated a lot of controversy
when it was released in 2017, but went on
to earn critical praise for its portrayal
of race and discrimination in a mostly white
upper class college.
Each episode of the series hones in on a different
character, exploring their relationships with
their fellow classmates.
Fans have been eagerly awaiting the second
season for months, and the wait is finally
over on May 4th.
Manhunt
Netflix's upcoming thriller Manhunt centers
on a Chinese lawyer who's been framed for
murder.
To clear his name, he has to team up with
a Japanese detective to uncover the real reasons
behind the frame-up.
Directed by kung-fu action icon John Woo,
Manhunt looks like an edge-of-your-seat thrill
ride that's definitely worth keeping on your
radar for May 4th.
Forgive Us Our Debts
In this Italian film, a man deeply in debt
is forced to start working for a violent enforcer
to collect other people's debts.
As he gets more involved in his new job, he
begins to suspect that his new boss and mentor
is worse than he could have ever imagined.
Forgive Us Our Debts premieres on May 4th.
Busted!
This show looks ridiculous.
It's a Korean detective comedy-slash-variety
show, and each episode will see the motley
clue crew solving a different mystery.
Are all their cases connected?
We have no idea!
The description says that there's one big
mystery behind the show, but based on the
trailer, we don't even know exactly what that
means.
Take a look, if you dare, on May 4th.
A Little Help with Carol Burnett
Comedian Carol Burnett made a name for herself
in the '70s with her sketch comedy series
The Carol Burnett Show, and she's been trucking
along ever since.
Now, she'll join the Netflix ranks with A
Little Help with Carol Burnett, a series that
will see the comedy icon and her celebrity
guests learn the ins and outs of the modern
world with a little help from tech-savvy children.
"Stay woke."
"Stay woke?
…I will."
Check it out on May 4th.
Safe: Season 1
Michael C. Hall hasn't graced the small screen
much since Dexter wrapped in 2013, but this
month will mark his triumphant return as he
headlines the upcoming series Safe.
In Safe, Hall stars as a father of two who
has to take matters into his own hands when
one of his daughters goes missing.
As he digs deeper into his seemingly perfect
suburban community, he finds more skeletons
than he ever expected.
The entire first season of Safe drops on May
10th.
Bill Nye Saves the World: Season 3
The Science Guy is back again with a new season
of his Netflix show Bill Nye Saves the World.
The series hasn't been met with a lot of fan
praise so far, although audiences did seem
to warm up to Nye a little during the second
season.
In the upcoming third season, Bill Nye will
tackle issues including evolution, food science,
and stem cells with a host of celebrity guest
stars.
Check it out on May 11th.
The Kissing Booth
Based on the book of the same name, The Kissing
Booth is a teen drama about a girl who finds
herself face to face with the hottest boy
in school, and her longtime crush, in a carnival
kissing booth.
Should she kiss him, even though he's also
the brother of her best friend?
Keep a defibrillator on hand, because these
plot twists are truly heartstopping.
Look for The Kissing Booth on May 11th.
Evil Genius
Netflix brings something new to the documentary
table every month, and this May they're adding
Evil Genius, a four-part series on the so-called
"pizza bomber heist" that happened in Pennsylvania
in 2003.
The robbery involved a pizza delivery man
who walked into a bank with a bomb collar
around his neck.
Evil Genius examines new details in the case
and takes a closer look at the mastermind
behind the whole, messed up episode.
Tune in for all the twists and turns on May
11th.
Cargo
Starring Martin Freeman, Cargo is about a
man in a zombie apocalypse who has to find
a way to care for his infant child even though
he himself is becoming infected.
Cargo is based on the 2013 short film of the
same name, which is one of the most emotional
six and a half minutes you're likely to watch
anytime soon.
If the film is as good as the short, and can
manage to offer some fresh surprises, it's
bound to be a hit.
Look for Cargo to stream on Netflix on May
18th.
Catching Feelings
After premiering at the Los Angeles Film Festival
in 2017, this critically praised South African
comedy finally snagged a distributor in the
form of Netflix.
The story is a quiet look at a young teacher
and his wife whose lives suddenly change when
a famous writer moves in with them.
Equal parts hilarious and heartwarming, Catching
Feelings looks like another great addition
to the Netflix lineup.
Check it out on May 18th.
Mob Psycho 100: Season 1
Based on an anime that's based on a manga,
Mob Psycho 100 is about a quiet middle schooler
who begins developing dangerous psychic powers.
All he wants to do is have a normal life,
but to do that he'll have to figure out a
way to control his powers, and his emotions.
The upcoming live-action series drops on May
22nd.
Terrace House: Opening New Doors: Part 2
This unusual Japanese reality show is something
of a sleeper hit with Western audiences, offering
a glimpse into the lives of a group of young
people living together in the same house.
Opening New Doors is the third rendition of
the popular series and sees a new group living
in a cabin in the woods.
If you haven't checked it out yet, now's the
time.
Part 2 of Terrace House: Opening New Doors
hits Netflix on May 22nd.
Explained
Ever wondered how cryptocurrencies work?
How about what goes on behind the scenes of
the K-pop industry?
Netflix's new docuseries Explained looks into
obscure topics like these to shed light on
some of the oddest mysteries of our time.
You can catch the whole show when it drops
on May 23rd.
Fauda: Season 2
Possibly the highest rated show you've never
heard of, Fauda is an Israeli political thriller
that was voted one of 2017's best international
shows by The New York Times.
Season 1 followed a military unit on the hunt
for a diabolical terrorist.
If Season 2 follows in the same footsteps,
you can bet that it'll be packed with action,
drama, and political intrigue.
Find out on May 24th.
Ibiza
In this romantic comedy, Gillian Jacobs stars
as a woman who takes a working trip to Spain,
with her best friends in tow, and ends up
on a search for a famous DJ on the island
of Ibiza.
Phoebe Robinson and Saturday Night Live's
Vanessa Bayer costar, along with Game of Thrones'
Richard Madden.
Look for it on May 25th.
The Toys That Made Us: Season 2
Netflix's documentary series The Toys That
Made Us takes a nostalgia-fueled look at some
of the most iconic toys of the '80s and '90s,
from Star Wars figurines to He-Man action
figures.
But with only four episodes in the first season,
fans were definitely clamoring for more.
Season 2 will delve into the rich stories
behind even more toys, with Legos guaranteed
on the horizon as well as a deep dive into
the numerous disasters that plagued Star Trek
toys.
Look for it on May 25th.
Trollhunters: Part 3
Few animated shows have garnered as much praise,
or been surrounded by as much tragedy, as
Dreamworks' Trollhunters.
Spearheaded by Guillermo del Toro, the show
is about a boy who uses a magical amulet to
travel to the realm of trolls.
After the passing of Anton Yelchin, who voiced
the main character, del Toro decided to go
ahead and release Part 2 as Yelchin's vocals
were already recorded.
What direction they'll take in Part 3 remains
to be seen, but we'll all find out on May
25th.
Sara's Notebook
Years after Laura's sister goes missing in
the Congo, a photo turns up that may give
Laura a clue to her sister's whereabouts.
She decides to head deep into the jungle to
track down her sister and get her home safely.
Filled with high-stakes adventure and drama,
Sarah's Notebook looks like a sure winner
for Netflix this month.
Look for it on May 26th.
The Break with Michelle Wolf
Netflix has enjoyed some success with its
weekly series like The Joel McHale Show and
My Next Guest with David Letterman, and they're
apparently eager to explore the format a little
more.
The Break with Michelle Wolf will see The
Daily Show's Michelle Wolf hosting a weekly
sketch comedy show.
Netflix hasn't released many details yet,
so we'll all have to wait until May 27th to
find out what it's all about.
Unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt: Season 4
Three seasons after leaving her underground
cult bunker, Kimmy Schmidt is still going
strong.
Unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt returns for a fourth
season on May 30th.
Original stand-up comedy
Big changes are on the horizon for stand-up
fans this May.
John Mulaney kicks off the month with his
new special Kid Gorgeous Live at Radio City,
and on the 8th, look for Hari Kondabolu : Warn
Your Relatives.
On May 13, Ali Wong takes shots at parenthood,
children, and pregnancy with her brand-new
special Hard Knock Wife, followed by Tig Notaro
Happy to Be Here on May 22.
Finally, May 25th sees the reunion of comedy
greats Steve Martin and Martin Short as they
land on Netflix with An Evening You Will Forget
for the Rest of Your Life.
That's all the Netflix originals coming in
May.
Now let's turn to all the other movies and
shows you can look forward to this month.
New movies
It's high-stakes action all the way this May,
with new highlights like The Bourne Ultimatum
and Hellboy II: The Golden Army coming to
Netflix's lineup on the 1st of the month.
You'll also be able to scare up plenty of
laughs, with a whole host of new comedy films
making their way to the streaming service.
The first of the month will see Amelie, Beautiful
Girls, Harold & Kumar Escape from Guantanamo
Bay, and The Clapper, to name a few.
May also marks the arrival of some great new
dramas.
On the 14th, check out The Phantom of the
Opera, and the day after that, look for Only
God Forgives.
That's definitely a selection to get excited
about.
For brand new documentaries, keep your eyes
peeled for 27: Gone Too Soon, a fascinating
glimpse into the surprisingly long list of
rockers who passed away at the age of 27.
That arrives on the first, along with A Life
of Its Own: The Truth About Medical Marijuana
and The Carter Effect.
And if the kids aren't excited about a new
pot documentary, don't worry: Family time
is going to get even better in May, with over
half a dozen new releases hitting Netflix.
Highlights include Shrek on the first and
Bridge to Terabithia on the 19th.
And on the 29th, Netflix is bringing in Disney
Pixar's Coco.
Netflix is also sneaking some brand new chillers
and thrillers into their selection, with plenty
of great films to scare the pants off even
the most die-hard horror fan.
Several classics are showing up in May, including
Red Dragon and Scream 2, both of which arrive
on the first.
"I'm gonna blame the movies."
New television
On the television front, viewers will have
plenty to choose from this may.
If you're looking for kids' shows, Netflix
has you covered with Season 1 of Barbie Dreamhouse
Adventures and Season 2 of Yu-Gi-Oh!
Arc-V on the first.
For more grown-up fare, look out for new seasons
of Girlfriends' Guide to Divorce on the 15th,
Scandal on the 19th, and Shooter on the 22nd.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!